يعني هذا النقاش ممكن يكون صعب لانه في
اتفاقيات وقعت بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وحركه طالبان في جهود تابعناها
في الدوحه لسنوات طويله لتوقيع الاتفاق
وانسحبت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
افغانستان لصالح طالبان بنهايه الامر يعني
وكان افغانستان سلمت تسليما لحركه طالبان
لذلك نتساءل عن المسؤوليه الامريكيه هنا
هذا صحيح
او هذا الامر غير طبيعي على الاطلاق
واداره
وقرارها لتفاوض مع الاطالبا من دون مشاركه
الحكومه الافغانيه
كانت
مفاجئه جدا وغير متوقعه
والقرار ايضا كان غير متوازن والاتفاق
الذي تم التوصل اليه
وكان بمثابه وثيقه استسلام والرئيس بايدن
بخلاف مشورته كافه قاده الجيش والاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه وحتى المستشاري
الدبلوماسيين قرر تطبيق هذا القرار او
الاتفاق
لا نستطيع ان ندافع عن هذا القرار واي
رئيس اخر ربما ما كان سيفعل ذلك
بل برايك لدى المجتمع الدولي اي دور في
افغانستان يمكنه القيام به لانقاذ البلاد
مع تراجع وضع المراه مع تراجع عمليه
التعليم للمراه مع هذه الظروف الاقتصاديه
وحاله الفقر الصعبه هناك
اعتقد بان المجتمع له اثر محدود وامكانات
محدوده ولكن يجب على مجتمع الدولي السعي
وراءه اي فرصه
وكل الاجواء غير مشجعه وكذلك عدم
الاستسلام في خضم كل ما يجري
المصر الوحيد
للمساعدات الاجنبيه
هو المجتمع الدولي لمكافحه المجاعه وهذا
امر مهم جدا
ومن المخيب
للاعمال ان تكون كل هذه المساعدات
الانسانيه محدوده جدا
وقرار الطالباني فيما يخص المراه ايضا
مخيب جدا
لانهم وعدوا باشياء مختلفه وكان يبدو انهم
سيسمحون للفتيات بالذهاب الى المدارس
وحتى بعد المدارس
الابتدائيه والثانويه ولكن القياده
الدينيه اتخذت قرارا مختلفا
والقياده الدينيه او غير الدينيه في هذا
الحاله اتخذت كما قلت هذا القرار
ولم تكن له اي شعبيه في افغانستان